when we came up with that idea that
hyper-physicality might be the thing
that the students might get their heads around
there hadn't been a global pandemic at that moment
how much that would mean was uh well a bit like
you're being ollie when you said how should we
live together little did we know that that would
be even more important the digital revolution i
mean that's 20 30 years old um was pushing us more
and more towards something that i suppose when i
started my studio i assumed would be less and less
role for some of the things that i was interested
in and i now feel silly for even thinking that
it would be less and less that the that somehow
real places would matter less and it's had the
opposite effect the digital revolution and this
pandemic has just accelerated in a sense what was
happening already has pushed the fact that um you
couldn't get away with lazy placemaking you can't
and now you really really can't as people are have
suddenly had the same lesson at the same time
across the entire planet that you can stay at
home you can kind of work you can kind of learn
you can kind of eat you can kind of drink you can
kind of watch interesting things and and it isn't
total catastrophe in fact in some ways it's it's
pretty good and so suddenly there's uh there's
something down on the table that uh that the
physical world if you're going to leave your home
if you're lucky enough to have a home that's okay
it's uh it's the the physical world outside
the public life beyond has got to really
be aware of how it connects with your
feelings and emotions because it isn't
an automatic thing that you have to engage
with to the extent that you did in the past